first i want to talk about a beauty
influencer with a special talent for
storytelling
literally i've heard so many people tell
me about her she's a makeup artist
turned true
crime phenomenon each week bailey
showcases the latest in makeup while
dishing the juiciest details of
notorious crime cases
which is so hilarious and i would have
never put those together
her viral youtube series murder mystery
and makeup has more than 400 million
views
uh let's get her on the line right now
what's up bailey
hi kelly hi i mean
how did you come up with it um i don't
know i mean like i've always been
fascinated with
true crime and makeup when i was a kid
my mom was a 9-1-1 dispatcher and she
used to take me to work with her and i
would like listen into the
phone calls which we laugh about it now
but looking back it probably wasn't the
best idea
for her to take me to work you know and
then um
like so i've just been obsessed with
true crying for as long as i can
remember
and as far as makeup goes i mean i
wasn't allowed to wear makeup growing up
until about in my 20s is when i started
to dabble
and i got a job at sephora and then i
started my youtube channel and it just
i mean it just it i'm here
no it's a lot it's taken over well i
know several people that think you're
hilarious by the way they are like oh my
god she's hilarious while telling these
stories
um so what surprised you the most like
researching all these stories
i think a lot well i used to be a big
believer that some people were just born
evil
like most people were just born evil but
after doing these stories for so long i
realized that
it all comes down to like how they were
raised and
also their upbringing their relationship
with their parents and then head trauma
is like a common thread in a lot of some
of the worst killers
and i mean it's just bizarre so i think
a lot of the times we
personally think like these monsters are
monsters and really
they're not they're just like the normal
people who live next door who just had a
really rough life
well that's just an excuse terrifying
news
campaign on here called you know good
neighbor and i'm
not terrified officially of my neighbors
who might not be good um
who might have i don't know fell off the
horse and bumped their head and might
kill me now
um that's why i can't okay i can't get
into true crime a lot because i
i was i was so invested and i watched
every day
thing i got so into it and then i
started become physically terrified
didn't sleep
because i was so terrified i was like so
they're probably know that one guy he
got to the third floor
so they could get up here i mean i sit
here and like play out scenarios so i
got so crazy but
i think it's hilarious we do i think
it's so innovative too nobody else is
doing it so thank you bailey for joining
us
thank you so much for having me
absolutely and you look beautiful so
well done on your makeup
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever